[Music]
what do we do when once our ego has
helped us climb the dominance hierarchy
and secure a mate why then should we
keep looking for a mate and how to
curtail that instinct well I think part
of the way that you curtail that ynx
instinct is that you have you have the
sort of life that you would have with a
mate the question is you know what's the
purpose of pair bonding and one of the
fundamental purposes of pair bonding
well there's a couple one is that it
solves the sexual access problem so that
you don't have to continue to obsess
about who you're going to be with and
and where and how and so you can get on
with other elements of your life but I
mean with with your mate you have to
decide well what does it mean that
you're now together you know your
there's companionship obviously in
friendship and their shared interests
you have to decide what they are and I
would say that you should continue
dating your your partner at least once a
week or perhaps twice a week because
otherwise the romance goes out of your
life
but then also you have to decide about
children and and eventually about
grandchildren because you know you're
gonna get old and oh you're gonna get
older and more mature and children are a
huge part of life and they get a bad rap
which is really unfortunate because you
know maybe I'm I'm different in this
regard and perhaps I am to some degree
but I never regretted having kids for
even one second because they're so I
mean all of a sudden you have an
intimate relationship with new people
that is as close as any relationship
that you've ever had you have the
opportunity to make that relationship as
pristine as you possibly can
I mean that can be a lot of catastrophe
involved in it but it's a great
opportunity and there's just nothing
wrong with having some additional people
that love you you know and so what you
do is you turn your attention to the
issues of maturity and your tune your
attention away from the issues of being
a juvenile and you do that partly by
knowing that it's actually better to do
so you know there's nothing more absurd
than the 40 year old 20 year old it gets
ugly
and there's something like there's
something like spoiled milk about it it
goes off and you have to gracefully
accept the challenges of each stage of
life and things work a lot better when
you do that much much better and you
also have to I would say work on and
perfect your sex life with your partner
and express what you need and want and
teach each other what's necessary to
keep things exciting and and new it's
not an easy thing to do but it's very
much worthwhile because then you can
combine sexual excitement with intimacy
and there's no better combination than
that
so and love that can all be nested up
inside love and inside you know what
destiny that's intertwined together
that's the best you've got man that
that's that's that's what life has to
offer and so that's what you do is you
accept the responsibility of the next
stage of life and you don't mourn the
past I suppose that also means that when
you're young you do what young people do
and so that you don't want to do it
again